bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous je
m'appelle Abdel Malik je suis artiste et
je vais réagir à des archives de Lina
bonjour Abdel Malik bonjour on est très
content d'être ici à Rochefort avec vous
pour le festival soeur jumelle vous vous
êtes né à Paris mais vous avez grandi
dans le quartier du 9 c'est là que tout
a commencé exactement à Strasbourg donc
alors vous le dites c'est votre amende
de la culture qui vous a permis de vous
émanciper on part à la rencontre du
jeune rappeur que vous étiez en 1998 et
qui avait déjà un regard aiguisé sur la
situation des banlieues
c'est un groupe d'amis d'enfance qui ont
grandi au quartier dans le Nord et qui
avait des choses à dire et qui ont
décidé de le faire par le biais de la
musique et par le biais du rap en
particulier
[Musique]
donc rappeur NAP voilà en fait j'ai
quasiment toujours vécu ici moi quand
j'étais gamin je rêvais d'être médecin
c'est émouvant d'être biologiste d'être
en fait nous on se disait qu'on allait
pas faire les mêmes erreurs que nos
aînés le monde d'adulte dans lequel on
est il est quand même plus dur plus
difficile que l'enfant ce qu'on a pu
avoir les mentalités on a l'impression
qu'elles se fâchisent la montée de
l'extrême droite
par exemple dans le quartier on vit au
quotidien on voit les les dégâts qui
rentrent de plus en plus tôt dans la
délinquance toutes ces choses là les
problèmes de des proches à nous qui sont
dans la toxicomanie toutes ces choses là
comme si les choses elles sont
radicalisées en général
c'est c'est émouvant c'est c'était
difficile parce qu'on était tous
voilà on était pauvre c'était mais il y
avait quelque chose de de fabuleux
c'était presque comme comme grandir dans
un village tout le monde connaissait
tout le monde et tout le monde prenait
soin de tout le monde et ça c'était
quelque chose d'assez assez rare et puis
le fait de toute cette diversité nous on
avait des Français originaires d'Afrique
du Nord et françaises originaire
d'Afrique du Nord français française
originaire d'Afrique noire des gitans
des Alsaciens les vaniers comme on les
appelait
et d'autres on avait tout tout le monde
était là toutes les ethnies et on vivait
ouais on vivait on vivait en harmonie en
fait on se posait pas les questions de
pour nous on était les gens du Nord quoi
c'était c'était fabuleux j'ai eu une
enfance
pauvre difficile mais d'une d'une beauté
incroyable et et ça a fait de moi
l'homme que je suis et regarder ça ça me
remplit d'émotion parce que d'une
certaine manière c'est un monde qui
n'existe plus mais ça veut pas dire que
je suis
nostalgique au point de me dire que
c'est plus possible que ça devienne je
me dis juste qu'on a eu la chance de
vivre quelque chose de particulier
positivement particulier et qu'on doit
le transmettre et quelque part ma
mission en tant qu'artiste c'est de
transmettre et de toujours rester fidèle
à cet endroit et aux gens qui qui m'ont
aimé qui m'ont vu grandir ce qui est
incroyable c'est à quel point le propos
que vous tenez à l'époque il résonne
avec aujourd'hui si on avait écouté ces
jeunes artistes comme j'étais qui
vivaient qui vivent dans l'œil du
cyclone d'une certaine manière il y a
peut-être des choses qu'on aurait pu
prévenir il y a des choses qu'on aurait
pu changer et ça ça me fait dire que
quand même on a besoin d'une société
avec plus d'écoute
de même truc fou de braquage de oh là là
dedans
l'archive tout à l'heure j'étais en
train de dire la jeunesse ce radicalise
oui j'ai le sentiment que elle sera
décalisée elle sera décalée encore plus
mais il y a quelque chose où nous il y
avait une sorte d'espoir il y avait
quand même aujourd'hui il y a quand même
on peut lire enfin on peut voir dans la
jeunesse beaucoup de de ouais de
désespoir ou en tout cas le fait de plus
nécessairement se dire que le changement
est possible alors que profondément moi
je pense que le changement est possible
on a beaucoup parlé de la police on l'a
accusé de bavure dans la mort de Naël on
va vous faire écouter ce que Mathieu
Kassovitz disait sur la police en 1995
lors de la sortie de son film line les
policiers ont des armes ils sont
ils n'ont ils n'ont pas la formation
nécessaire ils sont pas assez payés ils
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles et malheureusement
ils ont en plus ils sont obligés d'obéir
un hiérarchie un ordre
et ça tue individualité et puis
forcément ça amène des bavures mais
vous-même c'est pas un flic c'est pas un
film contre les flics parce qu'il y a
des bons flics il y a des mauvais flics
il y a toutes sortes de gens différents
donc on peut pas on peut pas englober
les choses même vous n'avez pas la haine
des flics il y a des bons flics il y a
des mauvais flics j'avais des mauvais
flics
l'idée de ce qui vous est venu
d'ailleurs d'une bavure policière il y a
une série de bavures en 93 il y a eu
qui s'est fait tirer une balle dans la
tête dans un commissariat du 18e et puis
il y a un enchaînement de choses qui
fait que on peut se poser la question
comment comment aujourd'hui dans ce pays
on peut se lever le matin et se prendre
une balle dans la tête le soir
c'est vraiment triste ce qui dit là
parce que on est en 95 mais en fait
c'est ça aurait pu être aujourd'hui en
fait et on met ça en miroir évidemment
par rapport à Nice qui a changé
finalement entre cette époque et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à l'époque on
n'avait pas les portables on pouvait pas
filmer et aujourd'hui on filme en fait
voilà ce qui a changé on a affaire à des
êtres humains en fait de part et d'autre
et si on parle d'êtres humains on doit
aussi parler de de formation et les gens
qui sont censés nous protéger et bien on
doit être vraiment on doit faire en
sorte qu'il soit en capacité de nous
protéger réellement et pas devenir ce
cela même qu'il combattent d'une
certaine manière c'est un sujet complexe
et j'ai l'impression qu'on a depuis
toutes ces années on a été dans le déni
et que maintenant ça nous revient juste
[Musique]
le foyer qui n'a en fait jamais eu et se
dit que peut-être
bientôt
il ne cherchera plus
et ça arrive autour de lui et ça pleure
au fond de lui faut rien dire et je t'ai
dit et soudain
soudais
derviche tourneur
vivant sur le pari temps il n'a plus
peur enfin il hurle comme un fakir de la
vie devient disciple sur le détroit de
Gibraltar il y a un jeune noir qui prend
vie qui chante dit enfin je t'aime à
cette vie
le jeune Noir dont vous parlez dans
cette chanson il va vers le sud pourquoi
il va vers le sud parce que finalement
il retourne assez racines c'est une
métaphore c'est le fait de dire que
finalement Nord-Sud Est-Ouest c'est
l'idée du cheminement intérieur c'est
qu'il y a un voyage avant même le voyage
physique qui est un voyage intérieur et
il y a cette idée de la reconquête de
son être et comprendre aussi finalement
que toutes ces millions de d'enfants de
femmes et d'hommes qu'on appelle les
migrants que moi j'appelle les exilés ce
voyage qu'ils font ils le font tout
simplement pour trouver un endroit et
pourront véritablement s'épanouir en
tant qu'être heureux comme n'importe
quel être humain et que c'est ça qu'on
doit comprendre on a l'impression qu'on
suit l'histoire de suivre les exilés
habituels et puis on se rend compte que
quelque part on est tous exilés en fait
sur le détroit de Gibraltar il y a un
jeune noir qui n'est plus esclave qui
crie comme les bras même la mort plus
entrave nous on entend parler de ces
histoires régulièrement à la radio à la
télévision est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
est impuissant ces situations l'idée
c'est de dire on reconnaît l'humanité de
ces gens qui qui viennent d'endroit
difficile etc et que Parentis on
comprend et on a envie de les aider etc
et de mettre ces choses en place et que
le politique doit comprendre ça doit
comprendre finalement que le destin de
ces exilés en fait c'est le destin de
notre humanité dans son entièreté et si
on comprend pas ça si on comprend pas
que l'autre c'est moi aussi et ben en
fait on vit dans dans ce cas de pire
qu'il y a notre monde moderne
c'est-à-dire l'individualisme
c'est-à-dire forme d'égoïsme profond on
continue sur votre parcours vous êtes un
amoureux de la culture vous avez étudié
la philosophie les lettres classiques
mais selon Pierre Bourdieu la culture
n'est pas accessible à n'importe qui une
des fonctions de la culture dans une
société c'est précisément de faire quoi
qu'il y a des choses qui ne sont
accessibles qu'à certains
quelle est la ne sont pas interdites
enfin vous pouvez très bien aller au
musée enfin ce n'est pas parce que vous
n'avez pas gagné assez etc elle joue son
inaccessible alors que vous devriez y
accéder alors ça je pense que c'est très
important pour le la perpétuation de
l'ordre social pour la perpétuation de
la domination des dominante si vous
voulez bon que il soit entendu que ils
ont le privilège de certaines choses
qu'ils ont le don certaines choses avec
le don pour la peinture qui conduit au
musée et qui donne enfin cette autorité
sociale nous sommes ceux pour qui il y a
des musées alors pour vous aussi mais
vous êtes exclu vous êtes exclu par
votre faute vous n'avez pas la grâce
intéressante
on est exclu parce qu'on n'a pas la
grâce moi je pense autrement je pense
véritablement d'abord qu'on doit
réfléchir à une sorte d'élitisme pour
tous mais c'est clair et c'est là où
c'est totalement pertinent qui dit c'est
clair si on vit dans un monde où qui
n'est pas que sur le rapport de force
celui qui oppresse et celui qui est
opprimé j'ai envie de dire et ben ça ne
peut que fonctionner comme il est en
train de dire et l'idée c'est de sortir
de ce paradigme-là donc il y a quelque
chose qui est double c'est-à-dire à la
fois une idée d'égalité mais surtout une
idée d'équité et si on parle d'équité on
parle aussi de justice parce que équité
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut pas
dire qu'on est pareil on n'est pas
pareil on est différent et vous c'est
votre motivation première quand vous
faites une œuvre d'art une chanson un
film vous vous dites je vais essayer de
toucher le plus grand monde je vais
essayer de changer les mentalités c'est
ça qui vous anime en tant qu'artiste non
ce qui m'anime en tant que artiste c'est
de créer des connexions avec les autres
de manière générale de me changer d'une
certaine manière en homme pont de fait
de dire que ce que vous croyez différent
en moi en fait vous l'avez aussi il est
important l'acte de créer pourquoi
ce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans une époque
dans une société où on nous parle de
vivre ensemble mais on vit ensemble déjà
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le faire
ensemble faire ensemble c'est la
capacité de de dialoguer avec l'autre
différent de s'enrichir les uns les
autres d'être en connexion avec d'autres
métiers avec d'autres regards sur le
monde et c'est comme ça qu'on fait
peuple alors il y a une forme de culture
qui qui divise un peu enfin même
beaucoup de sa création c'est le rap les
hommes politiques ont toujours eu la
manie de vouloir le censurer écoutez
Ariana titre qui s'appelle police dont
on va entendre un extrait tout à l'heure
et vous avez des petits soucis avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur je n'accepterai
pas conforte atteint au respect et à
l'honneur de la police nationale parce
que la police nationale c'est la
République le concert de sniper
programmé demain soir dans une boîte de
nuit d'Écrouves près de tout l’a été
annulé monsieur le ministre vous
comprendrez les mois les pétitions la
crainte des habitants que ce concert
engendre des troubles pourtant à l'ordre
public la démocratie doit protéger ceux
qui sont injuriés je déposerai donc
plainte contre des textes qui sont
racistes et antisémites le directeur de
la Maison Folie d'oisems se trouve bien
embarrassé par la polémique qui a surgi
autour du rappeur Orelsan dont un
concert est prévu dans sa salle le 24
avril prochain la liberté de création
n'empêche pas de respecter la loi et de
ne pas pousser à la haine inciter au
crime à la violence envers les femmes
puisque là cette chanson va jusqu'à
pousser au meurtre à l'encontre des
femmes jamais la chanson c'est une
fiction qui se place dans un contexte
particulier qui n'est pas réel une bonne
fois pour tout il faut qu'on comprenne
que le rap c'est de la poésie et à
partir du moment on parle de poésie on
parle de monde intérieur de chacun et
chacun a le droit d'exprimer son monde
antérieur tel qu'il l'entend problème du
rap c'est qu'il est connecté à quelque
chose qui est un caractère social le rap
est connecté à les gens en particulier
notamment des gens qui viennent des
quartiers populaires et eux sont déjà
stigmatisés donc d'une certaine manière
on stigmatise la bande-son de ces gens
là donc ça va beaucoup plus loin que
tout ce qu'on entend en réalité c'est ce
que disait Bourdieu tout à l'heure c'est
un rapport de force en fait tout d'un
coup il y a des gens qui ne sont censés
rien dire qui ne sont censés qu'obéir et
ben ils disent qu'ils ont envie de dire
et c'est ça la violence c'est ça qui est
perçu comme violence après ça fait aussi
partie de la tradition j'ai envie de
dire de la poésie on a eu des textes de
Paul Éluard de Boris Vian et d'autres
qui étaient des textes considérés comme
des textes polémiques on peut en parler
on peut en dialoguer mais la liberté
d'expression ça veut vraiment dire
quelque chose on ne peut pas se vanter
matin midi et soir de vivre en
démocratie et que tout d'un coup quand
il y a des femmes et des hommes qui
appliquent cette liberté là et tout d'un
coup on s'en offusque donc à un moment
donné ça fait aussi partie des règles du
jeu il faut accepter les règles du jeu
alors vous ça vous est jamais arrivé
d'être censuré il y a même certains
rappeurs qui ont pu dire que vous étiez
un peu lisse presque naïf
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque si je suis
lisse si je suis doux si je suis mais
c'est parce que je le suis réellement
pour moi la subversion c'est précisément
être capable de dire je t'aime et puis
d'une certaine manière aussi travailler
le beau dans son côté lumineux il y en a
d'autres qui travaillent le beau dans
son côté obscur c'est un choix quand je
pense à tout ça monsieur
[Musique]
il est tard Monsieur
il faut que je rentre chez moi
s'intéresse maintenant un prophète de la
chanson française vous avez repris ses
chansons et surtout sa gestuelle
[Musique]
le grand Jacques
le meilleur
ça c'est le plus grand rappeur c'est le
plus grand rappeur français de tous les
temps
[Musique]
grand rappeur français est belge
fabuleux
qu'on aura une maison
[Applaudissements]
un bon miel
si c'est pas sûr
c'est quand même peut-être parce que les
autres veulent pas parce que les autres
veulent pas
les autres ils disent comme ça qu'elle
est trop belle pour nous que je suis
toujours bon allez corriger les chats
j'ai jamais tué de chat ou alors il y a
longtemps ou alors j'ai oublié
[Musique]
Jacques Brel
qu'est-ce qu'être artiste et ben c'est
pour moi être artiste et être c'est
Jacques Brel il y en a quelques-uns
comme ça quelques-unes et moi j'ai eu la
chance de de travailler longtemps avec
son co-compositeur et pianiste Gérard
joinest et et pareil d'être
ami avec l'épouse de Gérard joanneste et
l'ami de Brel qui était ma grande
Juliette Greco tous ces gens là c'est
une famille artistique c'est un rapport
à l'art qu'est-ce qu'être artiste
qu'est-ce que ça implique
[Musique]
ouais c'est vraiment des des références
pour moi des modèles il faut que je
rende
[Musique]
chez moi
jusque dans la gestuelle aussi à force
de fréquenter des gens on parle comme
eux on bouge comme eux donc ouais ouais
donc il y a cette idée c'est presque
quelque chose qui s'est fait comme une
forme d'automatisme j'ai pas fait exprès
vous êtes né Régis failli être mécano et
vous êtes devenu Abdal Malik votre nom
de scène et de vie désormais vous avez
été élevé dans la religion catholique
vous avez même été en fond de coeur vous
allez choisir l'islam c'est une histoire
que vous avez raconté dans le film
qu'Allah bénisse la France on va vous
faire écouter une personnalité qui a
fait le même choix que vous c'était en
1975 je crois que toutes les religions
se valent alors pourquoi avoir choisi
l'islam parce que d'abord il faut en
choisir une je crois qu'il faut pas
rester dilettante vous savez en butinant
l'une et l'autre et parce que je crois
que nous avons besoin d'une espèce de
discipline je crois que l'homme s'égare
souvent dans des profondeurs est un
physique
de même que je pense que on doit faire
une danse de plus en plus libérée mais
mes danseurs font chaque matin la barre
parce que je crois que sinon il serait
libéré de rien il serait chaotique donc
même que je crois qu'on peut être
tolérant avoir une vue très large des
problèmes métaphysiques et en même temps
il faut pratiquer d'une façon
positive précise ce que je crois à la
technique et si vous voulez la prière
c'est pas une divagation c'est une
technique je trouve que c'est assez
juste ce qui est dit là je pense que la
religion est et la spiritualité ce qu'il
appelle la métaphysique c'est ces
consubstantiel en fait si on sépare les
deux la religion ça nous donne ce qu'on
peut seul on voit les aberrations on les
connaît et la spiritualité seul ou la
métaphore physique seule pour moi c'est
aussi ça devient des sortes de
d'élucubration des choses une espèce de
de réflexion qui qui tournerait à vide
une certaine manière d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que Maurice Béjart il
a un parcours qui est un peu similaire
enfin parcours spirituel qui est un peu
similaire au vôtre et lui il préfère
parler de cheminement plutôt que de
conversion je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui c'est que c'est c'est un
cheminement spirituel complètement alors
après les attentats de 2015 sont apparus
certaines fractures dans la société
française et il y a une partie de la
société qui qui a fait corps bien sûr
mais il y a eu certaines réactions en
banlieue aussi qui ont pu choquer on va
regarder un reportage tourné dans un
collège quelques jours après les
attentats
non pas tous Charlie devant ce lycée de
Drancy en banlieue parisienne les
attentats les caricatures de Mahomet
sont au cœur des discussions et le débat
est agité
terminale par exemple les dessinateurs
de Charlie Hebdo sont allés trop loin et
ces mots sont très durs je
suis pas fait les caricatures sur les
présidents et tous on s'en fout mais la
religion c'est
[Musique]
cette espèce de fracture en fait c'est
pas tant une fracture neuve c'est
quelque chose qui existe en fait c'est
juste que les attentats ça a révélé ça a
montré c'est comme un voile levé comment
expliquer que la République est le
concept même de laïcité c'est fait pour
nous protéger nous unir et c'est fait
précisément pour que chacun puisse être
croire en Dieu ne pas croire en Dieu
faire des caricatures enfin ce qui être
juif musulman c'est précisément pour ça
c'est fait en sorte qu'on puisse vivre
en harmonie ensemble pas juste vivre
ensemble mais en harmonie et en paix et
qui est des et qui est des zones des
endroits précisément qui joue le rôle du
sacré c'est à dire des endroits où
notre croyances personnelles intimes ne
prime pas de mon point de vue il y a
aussi quelque chose de l'ordre de la
pédagogie qui manque il y a quelque
chose du fait une certaine partie de la
communauté nationale qui a un sentiment
de non appartenance comment on fait pour
que tous ces gens là considèrent qu'ils
font partie d'un même peuple être
français ou être européen c'est pas une
couleur de peau c'est pas un sexe c'est
pas une religion c'est le fait d'avoir
des valeurs communes d'avoir une
philosophie commune qui nous porte et
est-ce qu'on a le droit de se moquer de
Dieu j'ai envie de dire on a tous les
droits on doit être capable d'entendre
l'autre même si on est absolument pas
d'accord avec lui et l'autre il a le
droit d'aller
aussi loin que la justice le permet j'ai
envie de dire dans votre histoire il y a
aussi celle de la France des colonies
votre grand-père Valentin a combattu
pour le drapeau français on va regarder
les actualités françaises une archive
qui date de 1945
et alors surtout que la France africaine
se lever l'armée qui deviendrait l'armée
du Gabon celle de la Syrie des Somalie
du Tchad du fetzal celle de Bir-Hakeim
d'Italie l'armée en fin de la libération
dans le combat et dans l'espérance
l'Empire était devenu autre chose et
plus qu'un empire la Communauté
française était née
[Musique]
le discours est beau la manière dont ça
s'est manifesté dans le réel c'est c'est
plus tragique justement mon grand-père
donc qui a fait à la fois 39-45 et
l'Indochine c'est des gens finalement
qui croyant en idéal mais c'est aussi
des gens qui ont été exploités donc
voilà ça fait partie de l'histoire de
France ça fait partie de notre histoire
on peut avoir des des mémoires
différentes mais l'histoire est la même
en fait et est-ce que en tant que
Français il faut avoir honte de cette
histoire mais c'est pas une question
d'avoir honte ou pas honte il faut juste
être capable de regarder ce cette
histoire droit dans les yeux et assumer
les conséquences là je parle par exemple
de de du cas des tirailleurs sénégalais
enfin des tirailleurs en général et tout
ça et puis comment aussi on va raconter
les histoires comment dire parce que des
fois on peut entendre des choses
aberrantes comme si on faisait pas
partie de l'histoire de France alors que
non seulement on fait partie de
l'histoire de France mais nos ancêtres
mes ancêtres ont fait en sorte que la
France est devienne ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui donc c'est important aussi
l'idée de reconnaissance l'histoire est
la même et on est tous des Françaises et
des Français une dernière archive
maintenant celle de votre maître à
penser celui qui vous guide et qui vous
inspire au point que vous lui avez
consacré à un livre voyez-vous
un écrivain travaille solitairement
et jugé dans la solitude surtout ce juge
lui-même dans la solitude cela n'est pas
bon ni
pour peu qu'il soit normalement
constitué un jour vient toujours où il a
besoin du visage humain de la chaleur
d'une collectivité cela explique
d'ailleurs la plupart des engagements
d'écrivains le mariage l'Académie la
politique
ces arrangements d'ailleurs n'arrange
rien on n'a pas plutôt perdu la solitude
qu'on se prend à la regretter on
voudrait avoir en même temps les
pantoufles et le grand amour les
académiciens tiennent absolument à être
non conformiste et les engager de la
politique
veulent bien qu'on agisse ou qu'on tue à
leur place mais à la condition qu'il
garde le droit de dire que ça n'est pas
bien du tout été fabuleux cet homme non
vraiment Camus c'est une figure très
très importante pour moi et
c'est vraiment un frère c'est vraiment
un grand frère c'est vraiment quelqu'un
une certaine manière qui a structuré mon
rapport à la chose rationnelle mon
rapport à la réflexion mon rapport à
l'esprit critique et lorsque Camus parle
de la de du constat de l'absurde et
qu'on se révolte face à l'absurde il
termine ce cheminement par
le fait de résoudre d'une certaine
manière cette équation par l'amour avec
un grand A ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure il y a quelque chose comme ça
d'intransigeant dans le fait de ne
jamais dévier de cette idée de l'amour
des autres et et de rester fidèle à ses
origines sociales etc il y a quelque
chose de très puissant et Camus est
vraiment pour moi une figure
intellectuelle fondamentale on passe
maintenant à la dernière séquence vous
allez avoir la chance de choisir la
personne qui va vous poser la prochaine
question
on voulait choisir entre Philippe le
fait Denise Glaser Thierry Ardisson et
Catherine Ceylac ah non Dennis Glaser je
suis obligé de laser c'est Denise Glaser
vous êtes classés dans les grands et
puis et puis vous n'êtes pas là et puis
vous êtes ailleurs et puis et puis qui
êtes-vous
je suis quelqu'un qui chemine et je suis
quelqu'un qui pense que la vie vaut
d'être vécue et que
le début le milieu et la fin c'est
l'amour voilà qui je suis merci beaucoup
Abdel Malik merci à vous